hi I'm Sammy grant and I have a dialect
coach I'm legally blind and one of the
reasons I got into dialect coaching is
because I love to hear people's voices
and help people find the range of their
voices so to help you I'm going to teach
you a few quick tips on set up your own
accents so I've got London and for
London you want to send the sound really
full within your mouth so send but with
energy forward and drop your our sound
so instead of car they say car and then
there's the Yorkshire accent which
sounds a bit like a combination of Irish
and cook me and they have this really
dull you feel about sound so they say oh
and a in the Yorkshire accent and then
there's the Irish accent itself and for
that you definitely want to keep those
are sounds kind of lean into them and
it's a bit of a tighter sound and you
want to really get out of your consonant
sound so they say nature said later and
then there's Scottish accent which
people always think sounds exactly like
Irish and it doesn't it's really really
different I think that wants to feel
like you're swallowing the sound in the
back of your mouth and then you want to
roll those arse and Scottish accent and
then we're gonna go to America we're
gonna go to Brooklyn and for Brooklyn
you want to have a lot of lip rounding
to make those sounds things you'll like
it
quacky and talk and swall and all and
then you want to have a lot of attitude
so that you've got that Brooklyn
attitude don't get in my way and in
there some Midwestern accent which is my
natural accent which has a lot of
flatness
said mom they say mom or they say Sammy
which is the way I naturally say my name
and then there's a course of southern
accents and this one that I'm doing
right now you keep your auger sounds and
you might hear it in Kentucky or
Mississippi or Tennessee or you know
lots of places and then you want to have
some length to your mouths so instead of
saying can they say can and then there's
the southern accent that doesn't have
all this which is dying out these days
it's much more put in the old generation
but for this obviously you drop the
awesomes and then you want to really
play milk pitcher and you can go up in
those pitches so you have that sort of
delicate sound and as MZ always fresh
accent and plus your French accent you
want to have these meaningful with
droopy lips or they kind of go boom you
stupid nip psycho legs X and then they
have that our side on the back of their
mouth
so instead of tomorrow they saved
anomaly not always watch accents and
then there is a German accent
which is very similar in many ways to
the French accent but it is very tight
very crisp and has a sort of harsh sound
and you don't want to have any lip
movement forward at all and then really
just a Russian accent which is in the
back of the mouth and this has that sort
of swallowed feeling again and you want
to have that curve on your edges
hello how are you don't overdo it don't
go how are you or they're going to pack
up a fur ball it's just hello and then
there's my favorite accent which is
which is the transatlantic accent but we
don't really hear anymore but you'll
hear if you watch Golden Age movies
because people that can happen were
taught to speak it and for that we want
to make sure that your sounds are really
round and that your our sounds are
really light that you have these really
maduk pitch changes like they do in
those movies and those are some my
favorite accents vizla a lot of people
think they don't have an accent but the
truth is every single person in the
world has an accent so you shouldn't
judge other people for the way they
sound and instead you should celebrate
the amazing diversity of sounds that our
world has to offer